hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll and
if you're a regular mindscape listener I
think that it's not too much of a
stretch for me to Guess that you
probably would consider yourself a
curious person curious about the world
curious about how things work and so on
and if that's true you've come to the
right episode of mindscape because we're
going to get meta on the concept of
curiosity by talking about curiosity
Itself by being curious about curiosity
what it is how it works the different
kinds of curiosity that motivate us and
the different purposes to which we can
put our own curiosity we also are doing
a little bit of the experiment we do
this occasionally we've done this a
couple times but we're going to have
more than one guest today Danny Bassett
is a physicist slash engineer slash
neuroscientist complexity theorist if
you like at the University of
Pennsylvania and Perry zern is a
philosopher at American University who
has previously written about curiosity
in a book called curiosity and power the
politics of inquiry and the punchline is
that Perry and Danny are twins so they
have been talking about this stuff with
each other for many many years now and
they share some of their thoughts with
us from these two different
interdisciplinary perspectives uh they
have a new book out called curious minds
the power of connection and that
subtitle is kind of the secret here to
their angle because they're trying to
say that we think of curiosity maybe
naively as here I am there is some
information or some mystery or some
puzzle out there I would like to go get
it right I would like to go learn it
it's kind of an individualistic kind of
thing but they want to emphasize the
connection part of curiosity you become
more connected to the world and you put
different pieces of information together
when you're curious you draw connections
between different pieces of information
Nation so it's a very fun conversation
for someone like me we sort of push all
the buttons I enjoy we talk about
networks in the brain and how those sort
of fit together to make us curious we
talk about political aspects of
curiosity what are you curious about how
is that impacted by society and
hierarchy everywhere are there places
that Curiosity shouldn't go are there
good things that are unanticipated that
come out of curiosity so if I've done my
job with the intro here you are now
curious to learn more so let's go
[Music]
thank you
Danny Bassett and Perry sir and welcome
to the mindscape podcast thank you
thanks so this is a you know an
experiment I've not I have done it a
couple times before having two people at
once on the podcast but it's different
formats every time so what I figured I
would do here in this case uh I will ask
you targeted questions right at the
start so that the audience can hear your
voices and therefore know what your
voices are going forward but then after
that I'll just let you chime in to
whatever questions you want so uh for
Perry first you've written a book about
curiosity
and curiosity is a word that just comes
with a positive valence right we think
of curiosity as a good thing like it
would be more daring to write a book
that said curiosity is bad you just
shouldn't have it
but but maybe one of the themes in your
book correct me if I'm wrong is that
even though we give lip service to
valorizing curiosity and saying it's
good we don't always follow through we
don't always institutionally or
societally nurture people's curious
impulses is that right
curiosity I think curiosity can be used
for good or for ill and
um I I addressed that a little bit in my
earlier book called curiosity and Power
uh and what I'm interested in there is
thinking about how structures of power
structures of of value in in Social
settings and social institutions inform
what practices and of curiosity get sort
of celebrated and lifted up and which
ones don't so I do think there's an
inequality that can that can arise in
how curiosity gets accessed and
practiced in curious minds we not only
redefine what curiosity is but we talk
about how that kind of curiosity that
that capacity to richly connect ideas
and people can be supported not only
from a brain Network structure
perspective but also from an educational
and a social perspective so we're really
excited to think about a new vantage
point on curiosity as connectional as as
linking ideas and experiences in people
and then how do we support that again
from a neural perspective as much as a
social perspective
I mean do you think that there are kinds
of curiosity that are bad or are you
just uh uniformly pro-curiosity
yeah I think that there are there are
formations or shapes of curiosity that
are not particularly helpful so the kind
of curiosity that drove a kind of
colonial approach to knowledge in which
one can come in from the outside one can
assess how people live or how people
move and just sort of
um take that objectively and and it's in
in some cases fetishize that difference
that's a problematic sort of curiosity
um but that's a structure of curiosity
that curiosity is making connections in
the way that we redefine curiosity but
it's doing so in shapes that really
alienate a particular group of people so
so the formations I think of curiosity
can be troubling
um although the Curiosity itself which
is the linking isn't necessarily so just
so the audience then can get an
impression of the different way that a
physicist bioengineer I don't know is
that right Danny how do we describe what
you do for a living
um yeah I guess I work at the
intersection between physics and
Neuroscience frequently
um which at in some cases is called
bioengineering okay I you know who wants
any of these disciplinary values to
exist yes that's what we're trying to
get rid of here but I just you know
different than philosophy at least in
where you're located on campus so uh to
Danny then you know the I think the
Prairie already mentioned it but right
there in the subtitle of your book the
word connections or connecting is is
very prominent and that's the other
theme that is impossible to miss in your
book that rather than thinking of
curiosity just as getting more
information or the desire to get more
information you really emphasize the
desire to connect existing information
or or people or ideas in different ways
yes exactly
um and I think that that's an
interesting Counterpoint to previous
accounts of curiosity which have
traditionally
um emphasized or foregrounded the
acquisitional nature of curiosity that
we go out we acquire pieces of
information
and I think that you know when you focus
on curiosity as acquisitional then you
can think of our process as sort of
going out and collecting pieces of
information and then bringing them back
home and putting them in a container of
some kind and the question is what is
the what does that kind of information
afford you well if it's independent
pieces of information then you can pull
out each piece and you can look at it
and you can admire it and you can put it
in a Cabinet of Curiosities if you want
to but if you want to do anything with
it it's very difficult because it's as
if you have a big pile of sand right but
once you think about curiosity as
focusing on the connections between
pieces of information then what you're
are doing is that you're building a
structure of knowledge that you can use
in the future it has a new affordance
more affordance than a pile of sand and
to illustrate this idea I want to pull
up a passage from John Dewey where he
says that knowledge is such a network of
interconnections that any past
experience will offer a point of
Advantage from which to get at the
problems presented in a new experience
and so what he's what he's calling out
is that number one knowledge is a
network of interconnections number two
knowledge allows you to go back into the
past and to appreciate what you have
seen to work there and then also go
forward connect forward in time to
change or alter or inform your decisions
about the future and so that the
connective nature of knowledge in a
single time slice but also towards the
past and towards the future gives now
knowledge a function it gives it an
affordance that you don't have if you
think about it as independent pieces of
information right and so we see very
clearly where the whole network idea
comes in which is something that you
Danny have been studying in the brain
for quite a while networks are
everywhere it's like a new it's a
buzzword right like people love networks
these days uh is there a philosophical
side to the network aspect of things the
fact that knowledge is just not a list
of facts but a list of connected facts
and connected in a certain very specific
way
yeah one of the things that I was able
to do is go back through the history of
philosophy and the history of Western
intellectual thought and think about how
it is that people have described
curiosity over time and looked for this
word connection connection link relation
um proximity right there's a there's a
number of words that I looked for to say
is there actually an implicit account uh
a connectional account or an implicit
Network account of curiosity in the
history of philosophy and indeed there
is and what was interesting is how rich
the connections were so it was it was so
it was not only the connections between
ideas and experiences and Sensations uh
but also the connection between oneself
and one's past self one self and one's
environment or surroundings oneself and
other people right there was just like
so many connections actually being
described as an essential component of
what curiosity is in philosophy but that
that narrative hasn't been called before
until this book well when we talk about
networks I mean to the person on the
street
there's a bunch of dots connected by
lines that's kind of a network social
network or whatever but there's a lot
more depth to what the professionals
think about when they think about
networks so I mean what what are the
concepts we should instantly have in our
minds when someone says look we have a
network in front of us
so usually
so independent units so an idea for
example we would call it a node in the
network and then two ideas would be
connected by an edge
um and so those are two pieces of of
jargon that are worth keeping in mind
and then the pattern of edges between
nodes can be very simple and sort of
rectangular the way a scaffold looks on
the side of a building that's being
redone or they can be very very uh
random and unstructured uh in a way that
um is is difficult to describe and so
what network science allows us to do is
to re
um redescribe those patterns in a way
that is mathematically rigorous
um and also provides us with
statistical assessments that allow us to
say this network is different than that
Network and the reason that that becomes
important is that when we're thinking
about curiosity as something that allows
us to build knowledge networks each of
us may be building very very differently
and have
um uh structures in our minds that are
quite different some of the structures
in our minds like might look like a
scaffold on the side of the building and
then other structures in our minds might
look very haphazard and network for
science provides us with the mathematics
to distinguish between the two and to
describe the Continuum between the two
so we should be thinking then about I
guess different different topologies is
that the word that we use to describe
networks we've had Steven strogatz and
other people Neil Johnson on the podcast
talking about small world random
networks grids are those the kinds of
things that we should be visualizing in
our minds yes absolutely so topology is
definitely the word
um and the way that we think about
topology is that it's the shape of the
network and it's a shape of a connected
pattern not in the shape of a volume but
we still think about it as as a shape so
yes those are the different sorts of
structures some of the different sorts
of structures that we can have in our
minds that connect pieces of information
together and Perry I don't want to put
words in your mouth are you literally
plotting little networks when you go
into the history of philosophy are you
actually looking at ideas connecting or
people connecting Etc that's a wonderful
question I think in some cases yes we're
definitely doing that when we're doing
it when philosophers are doing a careful
reading of a particular concept we're
trick we're tracking where it goes and
and what relationship it has between
thinkers and how it changes and morphs
in itself and what what words or
concepts or problems in the world it
gets connected to or just connected to
so I do think that they might there
might be an implicit Network method
within this kind of historical uh
practice good and and just put it all
together then the reason why networks
and connections keep coming up here is
is what I want to say curiosity is about
filling up our Network changing our
network does the shape of a network
itself imply a lack of something the
curiosity is then nudging us to fulfill
it's interesting there's a there is a
theory
USD in
such that curiosity is the drive to fill
an information Gap so as we are building
these networks in our minds we might see
cavities in the network or holes in the
network or what may be called gaps in
more common parlance and so that may we
may notice those gaps and we may want to
fill them almost like finding a puzzle
piece that fits into the spot that we
know there's something missing
um but but then there's the question of
uh what sort of shapes we are building
and that I think drives an interesting
question of are there some shapes that
provide us with cognitive affordances
and others that are maybe less useful to
us so it's possible we think and we
argue in the book to create knowledge
structures that are rigid
um that are are connected in in with a
particular topology that doesn't allow
for you to add anything more or to re
reshape or change the structure of your
knowledge when presented with a new
piece of information so there's the
argument that um
we may seek to build networks in our
minds that are space filling to some
degree but not to such a degree that
they can't change so there could be this
consistent trade-off in our minds
between filling filling in the holes and
leaving some gaps to enable flexibility
so we probably have all had this
experience where we are presented with a
new piece of information whether it be
about a person or a political idea or
even an emotion and we we have to We're
stopped in our tracks and we think I
need to rethink everything I thought
about this area or this person or this
political Endeavor and so that that
capacity to notice that there's
something that requires a reshaping of
the knowledge we have in our minds is
something that's really important for us
to to track and move in this
ever-changing world and it's really only
supported by building networks that have
holes in them enough gaps that they can
be flexible there's a really interesting
resonance for this in philosophy as well
early on right we have the famous
Socrates and he's well known not because
he ever had answers or that he was
looking for answers to fill information
gaps he was he's famous for his
questions which precisely undid the
connections and made bigger and bigger
and bigger gaps he said his goal was to
bring all of us into aperia which is a
Greek word that simply means I don't
know where I am anymore right and I
don't actually know what I think I
thought I knew what I think but I don't
know what I think about this thing and
and so I think that kind of maybe that
this early ancient practice of
philosophy was to reignite in a sense
that flexibility that Danny's talking
about with more gaps in our Network
knowledge Network structures to loosen
and to create more flexibility
um in what we think about the world well
I think that's a great example because
of course as we know Socrates got the
death penalty he was not uniformly
applauded by his audience and that's
where what I was going to ask I mean
don't we have this feeling especially in
our modern polarized era that a lot of
people don't want to change their minds
about things they're kind of satisfied
with their view of the world and when
they get data or information that
doesn't fit in they have strategies for
ignoring it or for compartmentalizing it
I think there is definitely a tendency
in this increasingly polarized world to
resist the the chances that are always
offered us to re-assess what it is that
we know
um I think that there's such a
defensiveness and an insistence that I
already know and I have I am on the
right side of things and that I think
that limits not only obviously our
ability to get along with one another
and build a political society that makes
any sense but it also limits our I think
our capacity to grow just as knowers and
beers in the world together
um and so I think I think it is
important to recover a greater sense of
flexibility in in the ways that we build
and rebuild and unbuild our knowledge
Networks
yeah and maybe just thinking through
even further how
um the the networks that we build
um could support that flexibility one
way that we've just been discussing is
allowing there to be enough gaps enough
disconnected pieces enough spaces in our
minds that we could
um reconfigure things so that's one way
is just to leave a lot of spaces in the
topology a second way to be flexible is
to actually break connections that we
laid down earlier
um and so actually in the throughout
much of the book we focus on the
building of knowledge and the laying
down of connections but at the very end
of the book we also underscore the
importance of breaking connections that
are no longer useful to us in our
existing knowledge structures and in the
way we interact with the world so I want
to I want to highlight the fact that
there are at least two approaches to
this mental flexibility one is leaving
gaps in the topology and the other one
is is breaking connections that we had
in the past do you have any good
examples of the latter of the breaking
of connections it sounds like something
that is difficult to intentionally do
I mean one example might just be
EPS movement so the Civil Rights
Movement for example if if there is a
set of connections that we call white
supremacy for example or some kind of
you know white people in general are
better for this and this and this and
this you need to break each of those
connections and the insistence of the
Civil Rights Movement is let's break
those right those associations of
whiteness with power with privilege with
greater education greater intelligence
greater capacity to lead et cetera et
cetera et cetera et cetera so I think
any
um any political resistance movement is
doing that specific breaking of
connections
so for example there's an implicit
Connection in the mind of many people
between whiteness and being a mermaid or
being a hobbit and these don't
necessarily need to be there when you
break them people get upset but maybe
it's just part of the growing process
yeah or a scientists
actually and and you know all of our
Fields were suffer from some of these
implicit connections or biases well I
don't know if they do this in philosophy
but uh scientists are very preoccupied
with the question of what people think
scientists look like and so at fermilab
they did an experiment where they had a
bunch of school kids come in and draw
cartoon images of scientists and then
meet a bunch of scientists at fermilab
and also draw it afterward and of course
before they were all pictures of Albert
Einstein and then afterward they were
much more diverse because that little
bit of exposure to the information
changed their minds hmm that's a great
study if you deal with philosophers too
I don't know what the answers would look
like though but but okay I mean let me
just this the the network the topology
stuff is great and I think it's a very
good angle or lens to look at curiosity
with but maybe I should also just give
you both an opportunity to give the
sales pitch for curiosity the fact that
it is I mean what what is the major part
of the sales pitch is it a normative one
that curiosity is something that is just
a good that we should strive for or is
there sort of a more practical thing
like curiosity is good for us it makes
us happier or better people I think one
of the sales pitches is that curiosity
is more complicated than we realized and
that it shows up in more diverse ways
than we expect so one of the things that
we press throughout the book is that
Curiosity has different styles uh
different ways of moving or different
ways of making connections so we talk
about three Styles in particular the
busybody the Hunter and the dancer the
busybody connects things quite Loosely
is interested in all sorts of things the
hunter focuses more on something
specific and makes tighter connections
more local connections and then the
dancer is someone who
is more creative and imaginative in the
connections they make when they're
curious and so what's what's interesting
here for us is not that these are the
end-all be-all of the styles of
curiosity but simply to turn our
attention to styles of curiosity to say
you know what the way that you think
curiosity shows up or might Mark you or
not Mark you is very limited right now
and we have we need a lot more attention
to diversifying the shapes that
Curiosity makes in networks and I think
that the network angle is really helpful
for that just to sort of follow up on
that I think that
um a little bit of background on what we
would commonly think of as a curious
person is useful so often particularly
in a classroom situation we think of
curious kids as the ones who will raise
their hand frequently or who sit in the
front row or who verbalize a lot of
questions right but we can also all
probably think of people in our lives
that are very curious people people but
who wouldn't be the one who sits in the
front row who wouldn't raise their hand
who wouldn't verbalize questions maybe
they're very curious in their minds
maybe they're a little bit shy maybe
they're more introverted maybe they are
curious by by reading a lot of books
instead um by not in instead of engaging
in their curiosity in more social
settings so
um it is it is definitely true that we
have in our minds this idea of what a
curious person is but we also have uh in
the background of our minds counter
examples and I think that the disconnect
between those two is important and that
disconnect is something that our book is
trying to fill to say that you know the
reason that we
um
it can have these uh counter examples in
our minds is because there are many
different ways to be curious but how can
we how can we um systematize that how
can we quantify it how can we categorize
styles of curiosity how can we talk
about what they do for us
um all of that requires the the sort of
network uh formulation and that
mathematical language and I like the
idea of the different styles of
curiosity because in some sense there's
an infinite number of things I don't
know so if I'm trying to learn more
things I have to choose some kind of
strategy right is that is that roughly
how I should think about these different
styles yeah I think the styles are
definitely strategies that each of us
can access but I also think it might be
that some of us tend in general to rely
on one of the styles for most of our
inquiry so it does give us more of a
personality angle on curiosity and and
and invites more of a let's get let's
get all hands in a more diverse kind of
group or team together who uses
primarily different styles of curiosity
um but then yes we also think that
they're accessible to anyone and we can
kind of practice each style and and be
able to use it when we need it most
and I think that we can individually
practice each style but then also
collectives of humans can practice the
different styles together I want to talk
a little bit about how single human can
can use these three but then also Perry
maybe I'll turn it over to you to talk
about collectives that might walk
through these Styles as they uh change
society
um so for an individual person I'll say
that first of all when I am reading for
personal pleasure I think I'm much more
of a busybody I read pretty randomly for
the one the books that are next to my
bed are did I did there's no through
line
um and that's fine I like it that way
but when I engage in a research project
I think that there I move through the
different styles of curiosity so the
very beginning of a research project in
science I will go to different
conferences sit in on symposia that may
have nothing to do with my current area
of research
um read pretty eclectically across
research articles and then eventually
I'll come up with an idea and I'll think
oh maybe that's what I should focus on
and then I become much more hunter-like
and seek New pieces of information along
a trail and that may include doing
experiments it may include doing
computational experiments it may be
developing Theory and then at the end of
a research project after I've discovered
something or my team has discovered
something then we um I think engage much
more in the dancer-like curiosity where
we connect up one that what we have
found to other areas of inquiry around
it and say this is how it could change
how we think about that theory or it
underscores this evidence over here or
it could be used in society in this way
um so I think the research process
itself sort of encourages us uh to move
through these different styles
sequentially but Perry maybe you can say
just a couple words about the way that
collectives can do this too not just
single individuals yeah so some of my
work has been to analyze social
um Justice movements or political
resistance movements and to ask what
role curiosity might have in those
movements in general curiosity hasn't
been thought as an important component
of social justice movements or political
resistance it's been thought instead
that resistors come in with the answers
you know they've already assessed this
is what needs to change this is the
problem uh and you don't need a whole
lot of curiosity with that you just have
to convince people that that you're
right about that but I think that's I
think that's a short-sighted way of of
approaching the issue I think that um so
again I I'll return to the civil rights
movement and say for example much of the
early work of the Civil Rights Movement
involved Gathering data about
segregation saying where does it show up
how does it show up where are the
stories where again where is it where is
the data about housing about education
about job and employment et cetera et
cetera et cetera so Gathering all that
information asking all those questions
those questions that's sort of busy
budding in a sense it's broad uh
investigation but then it moves to
saying you know what this is what we
need to focus on okay here are the the
specific policies that need to be
changed the specific people that need to
be spoken with right so there's there's
a much more there's a hunt there's a
huntering focus here uh to to what
questions must now be asked and then I
do think that regularly throughout uh
Civil Rights Movement there are these
moments of deep imagination about what
kind of world it is that we'd want to
create uh that could be as simple as
mlks I Have a Dream speech but there's
certainly many other examples and that's
the dancer move the dancer Curiosity has
to also be a heartbeat of political
resistance movements because you you
don't always know when you get started
um what kind of world you really want to
make uh so I yeah I just think that all
styles all three styles are also at work
in this in this uh social uh milieu I
mean I really like the idea of just a
political movement being a learning
process in some sense that's very much
not how it usually comes across as you
said right like we the existence of a
political movement in my mind more or
less presumes we know what the goals are
maybe we know what the strategies are
but but you're you're giving a different
slant to how we might think about that
yeah and I think it's more true to life
really but it's not it's not explicit I
guess like maybe things would be better
if political movements explicitly
acknowledged we have things to learn
right sure sure yeah
and it doesn't it sounds like you're not
valorizing any of the three kinds of
curiosity over the others
um but maybe implicitly or explicitly
some people do right I think Plutarch
you mentioned as someone who basically
back in the day said not in these words
but don't be a busybody be a hunter be
focused on your one area and and I guess
we maybe all agree that that attitude
lingers on in modern day Academia
absolutely yeah we've certainly had
these sorts of experiences you know
Focus stop being so interdisciplinary
and you know pulling your projects from
all over the place you know settle down
when are you going to settle down I just
retweeted a quote from uh William James
I think it was William James oh my
goodness I'm gonna forget who it was but
anyway uh one of his colleagues told him
you know up upgraded him for writing a
paper that was not in his area and he
says I am not a donkey I do not have a
field
I love
yes but presumably if that attitude
exists there must be some reason for it
I mean is there some reason to be more
hunter-like I mean is it even if we're
sort of skipping around from place to
place at the start like Danny said uh at
some point you gotta roll up your
sleeves and and focus and that's the
hunter curiosity
if it has to do with legibility so
because we are human and we live in a in
a social World
um our work is more legible to others if
it is uh if it uses the particular
jargon of a field and the methods that
are valued in that field
um and tackles questions that are
already known to exist in that field
like as soon as we connect to kind of
this history of a field then
um we our work becomes more legible it
has a clear audience we can communicate
it clearly to that audience that
audience understands us
um and so there's something there is a a
social benefit I think to
um to being more hunter-like I think
what's challenging when you become a
when you do when you illustrate this
sort of more busybody like approach or
the dancer-like approach
um is that people are you may be using
different terms than what a field
typically uses you may pull in a method
from from philosophy and have it speak
to Something in science and so people
don't know what to how to even evaluate
it and so that because it requires a lot
more effort from the reader or The
Listener or the audience to understand
and assess and um yeah so I feel like
communication and legibility are factors
that I think
push us towards the more hunter-like
approach but I don't know Perry what do
you think I think it's about what we
value right and and I think that there
are there could be ways of valuing
sharing stories more more of a
storytelling culture and sharing stories
in a way that allows us to care for one
another and to connect with one another
that would value the busybody more for
example or we could have a culture that
was much more interested in developing
new ideas than in sort of maintaining
what what it is and how it is that we've
approached certain questions so I I
think I think the current academic
preference for huntering is reflective
of a particular academic culture but
also a larger sort of especially Western
culture and I do think there are other
academic enclaves in other parts of the
world that do function differently and
value for example a more storytelling
based approach to to research that might
really lift up something like the
busybody
I will I will just own my embarrassment
I just looked up it was Max Weber who
had the donkey quote not William James I
don't know why my brain would have
confused those two people they don't
have a lot to do with each other but uh
okay so yeah there are
choices that we make in Academia or
whatever to valorize certain kinds of
curiosity they're not I think what
you're saying is they're not built in
like there's a sort of a maybe not a
conscious choice but a choice we could
have made differently there's also
people who are just anti-curiosity uh
either uh out loud or quietly and I
guess Augustine Saint Augustine is the
example that you brought up of someone
who's just like oh I have all this
curiosity it's terrible God must be very
mad at me
yeah exactly there's a lot of that in
the history of Western thought so how do
we still man that like what what is the
argument for not being curious like what
what is the there has to be again some
reason why people would think something
like that well in that case I think one
of the reasons for the very long
tradition of being against curiosity in
the western
um intellectual tradition is that
Curiosity was conceived as a very
self-directed individual interest uh
sort of practice and one that didn't
take into account that God might want
you to know something different uh so it
was it's really that it that it comes
from us the Curiosity comes from us and
serves us it that it felt sort of
selfish and and proud in the old way uh
and and that's part of why it was
dismissed in favor of Wonder for example
because wonder is much more uh capable
of us of a reverence in knowing
um and so that was that was prized in it
instead but then there's a really
interesting moment right where early
modern science starts where the two of
them sort of flip and wonder becomes the
thing that's less uh supported because
it's associated with
um you know kind of like simple thoughts
and and not a really
um careful attentive educated erudite
approach to things which would require
curiosity the weird why why things like
that flip but well it's very interesting
to me because the dichotomy I've always
thought about myself is not uh curiosity
versus Wonder but awe versus Wonder and
I come down on the other side I come
down the pro Wonder side awe seems to be
awe more like just standing silently
contemplating uh this amazing thing
whereas wonder is more like I wonder why
like wondered as a connotation of
curiosity to me a little bit maybe
that's just because the English words
don't map on exactly to the uh Concepts
we're talking about
yeah it really depends on the moment
we're we're we're discussing in the in
the history
um what Wonder
the term wonder what connotations the
term Wonder had and and I and I think
it's interesting to ask today what
connotations the term Wonder has and why
isn't Wonder for example as uh as as
everywhere as ubiquitous as curiosity is
why isn't Wonder in all of our higher
education vision statements what why not
uh what does that say about the kind of
configuration of our approach to
knowledge these days
well it does it does seem like just with
the current Zeitgeist uh coming out
anti-curiosity would would not be very
popular but I think you do make the case
that you that's the lip service but
there are certain types of curiosity
which are discouraged or or I mean
either explicitly discouraged or frowned
upon in some way I mean is it easy to
draw or possible to draw a line between
okay curiosity and naughty curiosity
that we should try to resist Danny it
looks like you are ready for that
question
well actually I was thinking about
um your construction of the spectacle
curiosity so I was nodding because I had
that peace in mind
yeah so in my other work I talk about
again formations of curiosity that are
troubling and the spectacle Erasure
formation is something I talk about and
it is a hyphenated term the this
approach to uh um people or subjects
where you spectacularize you sort of
celebrate or lift up in some way hey
this is a weird interesting curio of
some kind but even in that lifting up
you're essentially erasing the the
meaning in the context of that object or
that person or that culture so that's
certainly one of the more troubling
formations I think of curiosity that
have been around for
so kind of long time curiosity as a uh
almost dehumanizing or or something like
a way of of
treating a person or an idea or a
culture as an object of curiosity but
nevertheless an object rather than a
subject yeah exactly yeah see I've taken
philosophy classes you can't get the
stuff past me uh yeah no that that does
make perfect sense but there's also I
guess what I was I was aiming at I mean
that seems like a perfectly legitimate
uh
worry about curiosity but there are
people out there Banning books and not
let people uh explore different things I
mean there's also a sort of
I I I don't want to just dismiss it out
of hand but there's also a human
resistance to being curiosity to being
curious too far in some sense or about
things that you shouldn't know about
Network flexibility or network uh how
networks get stuck I think um part of
the book Banning process is a network
getting stuck and unable to flexibly
respond to how knowledge is changing and
is changing often in response to
marginalized groups of folks who are
gaining some kind of foothold and voice
well that's one of the ways I would
approach that
well I like that because I wanted to
move I I wanted to go a little bit in
more detail uh on Danny's side about
what's happening literally in the brain
because we have networks of ideas and
that sounds a little abstract but the
brain is literally a network of neurons
talking to each other right 86 billion
of them and there's structure there and
I guess one of the very cool things that
I think I learned for the first time
from one of your talks is that not only
do the neurons group together within the
brain like there's a whole bunch of
neurons working together on the same
problem but and again correct me if I'm
wrong an individual neuron over the
lifetime of a person might switch groups
might like it might be used for one
purpose early on and then be used for a
totally different purpose later on is
that right yes yes so there is
absolutely a flexibility in um the
function that particular neural units
might perform over time and that
flexibility is is useful it is it is
predictive of how much somebody will
learn over time it's also correlated
with how cognitively flexible we are
um so how easy it is for us to
um change from one kind of uh cognitive
process to another kind of cognitive
process so cognitive flexibility you can
think of as how easy is it to switch
from
um doing math homework to uh talking to
my grandmother so these are our wildly
different cognitive processes some
people find that sort of transition
really difficult other people find it
easier and that degree of ease is is
called cognitive flexibility so that
cognitive flexibility is supported by a
neural flexibility which is how
independent neural units in the brain
change which other neural units they're
communicating with and and kind of why
what they're communicating
yeah so that that neural flexibility is
is really key I think to understanding
how we
um
change and learn over art I mean it's an
obvious obvious hypothesis that our
neuroflexibility goes away as we get
older is that uh something that the data
could speak to
that's a really interesting question we
have studied neural flexibility in young
uh young adults and childhood uh
lifetime life skills
um but not at the older age range
um so that's that's something that's
sort of an interesting open question is
whether in very late life
neural flexibility is altered we don't
know
um but I think what's interesting is
that uh there is a suggestion that that
there are while there may be a change in
both neural and cognitive flexibility in
late life there may also be a
strengthening of other kinds of
cognitive functions and by extension
other kinds of curiosity that may be
present in in late life in comparison to
early life
um and that's something that I think
we're really excited to dig into more
deeply in the future and the ideas that
we're learning and are curious about
as you point out they have a network
structure of their own and our brains
have a network structure are they
analogous mirrored or they just both
there doing separate things
well they're uh they're similar in their
topology in the sense that both the
network structure of the ideas and the
orchestructure of the brain they're uh
they both have a small world
organization they're not perfectly
rectangular or triangular they're also
not perfectly random they have
interesting intermediate structures so
that's definitely the case the other
important I think correspondence is that
there are particular pieces of the brain
that are coding for the network
relations in the world around us so
there's this piece of the brain called
the hippocampal enter rhinol system it's
a mouthful
which uh which when when we are
presented with information will code
what the pieces of information are and
then also which pieces are connected and
and by half distant they're connected so
it codes connection versus
non-connection and it codes instance of
the connection and this hippocampal and
terrinal system creates these cognitive
Maps or conceptual maps and their
Network Maps they're maps of of our
world in this connective pattern so
there's there is an explicit piece of
the brain that's actually helping us to
understand the network organization of
our world the network the brain is very
smart I'm always impressed with the idea
of what it can do and just to drive that
home the I love the example that I think
I heard you give once maybe even in the
book I forget but when you're talking to
somebody and you're trying to explain to
them a bunch of ideas the the linear
nature of time means that the ideas are
going to come in some order but what you
want is to give a whole network of ideas
that are connected to each other in some
way and there's some cooperation between
The Giver of the information and the
receiver of the information to basically
reconstruct that Network even though the
actual transmission is just linear yes
exactly yeah so when we communicate we
communicate in a line I can only say one
word in front of the next and same with
you but what we're actually trying to
communicate to one another are whole
structures of knowledge
um and the question is how do we do that
what pieces of the brain are important
for that right um we're all in society
right we live in a society as someone
famously once said and this is I guess
where Perry's work comes in more
um it feeds back like what we choose to
learn and be curious about we we just
talked a little bit about how a
political movement can be learning but
also what we want to learn is affected
by the politics affected by what Society
is telling us right absolutely yeah and
this is part of this is what is one of
the angles that's really interesting for
me is to think about what kind of
knowledge networks we gain simply by
being raised in a particular family in a
particular location in particular social
structure and culture et cetera Etc
um and we just kind of imbibe versus the
kind of knowledge structures that we are
actively building on a daily a day in
and day out basis and what might be the
relationship between the two
um I think you might you might at first
think that the the network structures of
knowledge that we imbibe are from our
surroundings have sort of all these
biases and maybe I can resist those by
building my own knowledge network but I
don't think it's quite that simple and
certainly what we know from the the
environment's effect on our own uh brain
function even when I am leading my own
inquiry right I can I can bring in and
practice and and further certain biases
as well but it is interesting that the
one is active and the other is more
passive and I think learning happens in
both ways
and on the active side you know Society
is impacting us just by being around us
and being where we live but sometimes it
actually actively polices our curiosity
and tells us not to go there and you
know we already mentioned the book
burning but are there more like subtle
microaggression nudges kind of ways that
in which being curious about certain
things is discouraged by the people
around us sure I mean I think maybe not
so subtle is for example the the work to
suspend you know critical race Theory or
learning racial histories of the US
um the very very long fights to try to
get LGBT history into the K-12 schools
you know these are these are policy
level arguments about what people should
and shouldn't know or should and
shouldn't be curious about uh but I
think on an everyday level
sure there's clearly certain things that
are valued and and you may be celebrated
for being curious about those things and
then there are other things that are
peripheral in some sense it could be for
because of a relationship to a
marginalized group it could be for other
reasons
um that you that you might be really
curious about but no one else is really
that curious about and you know and and
you might be just therefore discouraged
or at least not like celebrated for the
fact that you're curious about that
thing and it's interesting to think
about the history of science I think in
this respect because certainly there
have been questions that have driven
certain scientists and philosophers as
well but
um to you know say I really want to know
this and their surrounding culture at
the time were like that's a really
ridiculous question what are you wasting
your time on you know
um and you know they don't get funding I
mean that's a structure that supports or
doesn't support certain kinds of
questions and Curiosities where is the
funding where is where are the
collaborators you know where are the
Publishers lots of older folks or you
know a couple hundred years ago good and
get their pieces published even if
they're groundbreaking philosophy or
science so I think it's all around us
the the policing of of curiosity I think
it also happens even at the
undergraduate level two so when when
kids are younger well and in classrooms
as well but the example I wanted to
bring up is of Robin wall kimmerer who's
an indigenous scholar of
um botany and uh she recounts going to
um
undergraduate for an undergraduate
degree in botany and saying that what
she wanted to do was to understand why
Goldenrod and Asters when they exist in
a field together are so beautiful and
her
um professors were like that's not a
question that we ask in this field that
um and she continued to follow that and
did a lot of work uh at the intersection
of understanding plans our perception of
plants our valuation of plants and how
that's different among cultures and and
has you know had a wonderful career has
inspired so many people across the world
but again it was it was started by a
question that was dismissed out of hand
as a relevant question
but this is this gets us into very
tricky territory and I say that in a
very sincere way that I don't know how
to think about these things because the
sort of other side of the political
spectrum is using very similar rhetoric
to say that their ideas are being shut
down right by the intolerant people on
the other side like all they want to do
is say that maybe white people are
smarter than black people and they don't
get to do that without being criticized
and
are there substantive lines to be drawn
between what is it's worth being curious
about and not or should we just say that
like everybody should be curious about
everything and but we should just you
know be ready to accept whatever it is
that we learn yeah I mean I think for us
we're committed to thinking about
supporting Curiosities that create
more support for more diverse ways of
thinking about the world especially in
response to histories that have excluded
those knowledges and that attachment to
histories is really important because
then we can talk about things like
um the enslavement of African people in
the U.S right we can talk about the
genocide of indigenous people in the U.S
we can talk about the laws that have
been long-standing that have penalized
and criminalized LGBT life so I think in
relationship to history and the lives
that have not that have not been able to
live first of all
um and that and that deserve to have
more of a place in in our
um schemas of belonging and of knowing
that's that's the kind of curiosity that
we want to support
I guess one worry is that the lens of
curiosity doesn't distinguish between
ideas that maybe have been discredited
and ideas that maybe have been
suppressed for political reasons right
and and I want to be Pro curiosity I'm
very pro-free speech if some crazy
campus group wants to have some crazy
speaker on campus and they're not
forcing me to go I'm very much in favor
of letting them go but I don't want to
respect it either I don't I don't want
to say like that should be taught in a
classroom or something like that so do
we need I guess maybe the question is do
we need more than just a pro-curiosity
attitude uh to help us distinguish with
which ideas are worth delving into and
which we've moved Beyond by now
yeah something I argue in my first book
on curiosity curiosity and power is that
Curiosity needs companions so this is my
answer to that question curiosity needs
companions it needs to be alongside of
other values and Investments That guide
our inquiries together
yeah and I think going back to an
earlier part of our conversation
um we need a curiosity that's that is
not objectifying when what we're curious
about is not an object right
um so I think that ensuring that we are
curious
um and and acknowledge and respect the
subjectivity of um those around us is is
really key and in a sense
um our focus in the book on curiosity as
connection and that we push that
connection to me not just between ideas
but also between people requires or
brings in an ethics of interaction
between humans
um that is is Central to
um what curiosity for us is doing and
can do
I had Paul Bloom on the podcast a while
back I don't know if you know his work
he wrote a book He's a psychologist he
wrote a book against empathy and I'm a
pro-empathy kind of guy so I you know we
we disagreed but his attitude his
argument if I can try to repeat it and
I'll hear what you have to say about it
is
he couldn't contrast roughly speaking
empathy to rationality he says you know
when we're judging people when we're
whether we're on a jury in a court or
we're trying to set up Society uh
empathy sounds good but it's a lot more
easy to be empathetic to people like us
than to be empathetic with people very
very different so he prefers that we
just aim to be objective and rational
whereas my argument was well just like
empathy isn't always easy rationality
isn't always easy either and if you
think you're being rational but not
thinking about how other people would
view the problem you can fool yourself
into thinking that your rationality is a
little bit better than it is I'm not
sure where I'm going with that but uh it
sounds like you you want to couple
curiosity with empathy in an interesting
way
yeah absolutely I mean I think that when
you are I think that maybe a counter I
would have to empathy is easier for to
have toward people who are like us is
that we need to be more curious about
the experiences and beliefs of people
who are not like us so that we can also
have empathy for them I would not say
therefore let's remove empathy I would
say no we need empathy for for lots of
different um kinds of experiences but
that requires a curiosity of how those
individuals got to that place
um and why they think that way uh Etc
yeah I was just going to say that the
contrast between empathy and rationality
there is one I don't particularly buy
because I think that rationality has
been shown repeatedly to have inbuilt
biases rationality is simply if I have a
number of assumptions and a set of
information I can do you know make sense
of that logically from from the
beginning to the end but maybe the
information that you have is biased
maybe the um
the relationships between the data have
been constructed in a biased way well
you can be as rational as you want on
walking that Network and can still like
be making a bad move right or or
misunderstanding the situation so I
don't see rationality as as something
that gets us out of whatever the
problems of empathy or subjectivity
would be
okay I think I get that I hope I did a
good job of uh repeating Paul Bloom's
argument rather than uh caricaturing it
but but that was a useful response so as
we're winding up I mean let's uh give
some actionable take-home messages to
our listeners out there but I guess
before we do that
was there a worry among your Publishers
or uh your faculties that what you were
writing was really just a self-help book
or you know rah-rah like learning new
things is fun book that you have to
climb uphill against that kind of
resistance
no I think the book itself is so richly
written and so deep steeped with our own
research but also with so much
scholarship and literatures of centuries
no one was worried that it's a light
fluff thing right and I don't think that
you can read it in that sense I don't
think you can read it easily right I
think the book itself demands that you
take it slow and there's going to be a
lot of stuff you're unfamiliar with no
matter what angle you're coming at the
book from and we're hoping that that's
exciting Danny
yeah absolutely I mean I think that
um I think what we are offering is a a
sort of conceptual change it
related to our experience as humans
um it's it's not a self-help but it's
it's a question of sort of how do we
even make sense of the way that we think
and the way that we think with one
another and and that is
um I think that's a that's a very
different style or genre well the
demandingness of the book raises its own
interesting question which is you know
curiosity seems so easy but satisfying
one's curiosity can often be kind of
hard there's you know there's an effort
involved and I know that personally like
sometimes I just don't have it in me
like I just want something easy and
fluffy but there is an interplay between
what we want to learn and the effort
we're willing to put into it which I
come across because my own book coming
out that just came out rather uh has a
lot of equations in it and it asks the
reader to sit through the equations and
I have to convince them it's worth the
effort Danny this reminds me of your
stories of of um effortful walks and
mentors
oh yeah
so um
books are your book um and our book they
are when readers come with us on that
Journey it's as if they're walking with
us and they're walking through the ideas
it's as if they're walking through a
network right
um and the question is each of us are
what kinds of walks do we like to take
and with whom
um and are we willing to take the hard
walks or do we want the gentler walks
and the answer is maybe we want both but
I um I vividly remember our grandmother
um taking us uh hiking when we were
probably three or four and she loved
this path that felt as a three or four
year old as if it was straight up and it
was so steep
um and maybe it was like I don't know
100 yards I don't know how like long it
was but we would want we would beg for a
snack break halfway up because it was
that strenuous
um and uh we loved hiking with her but I
remember feeling that that was so
challenging and feeling so relieved that
we were allowed to have a snack a break
and then we would pack very carefully
before this this hike because of the the
strenuousness anyway
um it makes me think more generally
about the kind of mentors that we have
in our lives whether scholarly mentors
or personal mentors that may show us
paths um of mind that may show us
different styles of curiosity that may
take more or less effort from us and as
we
um kind of expose ourselves to those
different influences we can choose you
know which is the style of curiosity
that I want to model myself after which
is the path out I really want to take
with you as an author of the book
um and I yeah I love the fact that we
have choices
um among our friends and colleagues well
this goes to the advice question I know
the giving advice is often a weird and
useless thing but we've all been
advisors to students right and you know
it's one thing to say you've given
examples and I've seen examples in my
own work of
bad advice being given to students
because they were curious about some
question they were told no that's not
the kind of question that we answer
that's not interesting that's not
academic it's not intellectual scholarly
whatever but
I'd like to still think that some
questions aren't as good as some other
questions like I mean this is I guess
part of the advice question how do we
decide between the right directions to
let our curiosity go in and where we're
just being a little bit self-indulgent
foreign
that's interesting it reminds me of this
class that I'm teaching right now to
undergraduates at Penn
um and it's on what I'm trying to do is
to say that when we ask questions we are
engaging in a movement of the mind and
the question for the student is what
mental movement is that is it a slide is
it a step is it are you flying with
imagination
um and in Quant and sort of describing
the kind of movement you're making with
your mind you can then say is that
movement useful for This research
project that we're on right now and
sometimes the answer might be yes and
sometimes the answer might be no but at
least understanding the mental movement
and putting words to it can help both
the mentor and the student I think
evaluate the utility
and it's really important too if you
decide that the movement is not
particularly useful for the project at
hand to not immediately then say it's
value-less right right
um we we do really want to encourage in
ourselves and in our students uh to to
practice some Curiosities that are not
it's not clear what the what the
Cash Out is right and and it's often
those things that end up being the most
insightful most exciting projects
eventually but they just need their own
time I mean maybe the best thing an
advisor can do is to not crush the
spirit of the student they're trying to
advise or to put a more constructive way
which I think you did in the book uh
maybe it was with reference to young
kids but I think graduate students also
works or maybe even colleagues different
people are going to be curious in
different ways and acknowledging what
that is and helping them develop that is
more your job than helping them change
into a different kind of researcher
absolutely yes any advice on how to do
that before we go
uh just to be a little bit more curious
about them so I think channeling a
little bit of social curiosity is
important trying to understand where it
is their mind is moving and how
that makes perfect sense so Perry zern
and Danny Bassett thanks very much for
being on the mindscape podcast
thanks for joining us
[Music]
thank you
mama
[Music]